[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
the is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
we are live.
WOLFF DOBSON: Bravo.
TODD KERPELMAN: Hello.
All right.
Welcome to Google Games
Chat number
five, still not canceled.
COLT MCANLIS: Alto cinco.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I guess we
should start by apologizing
for last week's episode not
making it onto YouTube.
WOLFF DOBSON: Our awesomeness
cannot be compressed.
COLT MCANLIS: It was probably
for the better that that one
didn't make it on.
TODD KERPELMAN: In retrospect,
I think we probably had a
little too much gratuitous
nudity
that probably violated--
COLT MCANLIS: Todd.
TODD KERPELMAN: I thought
it was artistic.
I thought I was artistic.
But apparently, those--
WOLFF DOBSON: We don't have
a release for those
parts of our bodies.
COLT MCANLIS: The Supreme Court
will tell you what's
artistic and not.
TODD KERPELMAN: I know
it when I see it.
I'm just saying, I thought it
was tastefully done, and it
was a beautiful thing.
But apparently those people at
YouTube just did not agree.
And so those of you who missed
the last episode, episode
number four, it's been
lost in the ether--
WOLFF DOBSON: You missed out.
That's what I'm saying.
I don't think it'll
ever happen again.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: A whole
lot of Todd.
TODD KERPELMAN: So we are going
to move off of this
uncomfortable topic and go
into some introductions.
To my left is Daniel
Wolff Dobson, Dr.
Daniel Wolff Dobson.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm a doctor,
and I play one on Google
Developers Live.
TODD KERPELMAN: To my immediate
right is Colt McAnlis.
Say hi, Colt.
COLT MCANLIS: Hi, Colt.
TODD KERPELMAN: And to his
right is John McCutchan.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hey, everyone.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So actually I want to start by
asking, you're a doctor?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: I did not
know this until--
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm not the kind
of doctor that does surgery,
although maybe the occasional
unnecessary surgery.
But no, I have a PhD in computer
science in artificial
intelligence.
I worked on intelligent user
interfaces, so interfaces that
had an idea of what it was
you were trying to do.
And then because it had a model
of what you're doing, it
could help you do it better,
more or less.
Old AI PhDs are not awesome
reading, because a lot of it
is like, well, yeah, that
would be a good idea.
And now, here, 10 years later,
it was a good idea.
We should have done that.
TODD KERPELMAN: Is there an
example of this put into
practice that you'd be able
to point to and say--
WOLFF DOBSON: You don't want
to ask a PhD to talk about
their thesis.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
is probably true.
WOLFF DOBSON: That
gets ugly quick.
But I will say that after I did
some post-doc work doing a
lot of interesting things,
rendering Mars Rover data and
things like that, I was like,
I think I'm done with this,
and joined Sega Sports and
started working on basketball.
TODD KERPELMAN: Sounds
way more fun.
WOLFF DOBSON: Which was very
much AI, although it's
interesting, because so much
of the AI in console games,
especially of that era, is very
much reactive planning,
which is a classic theory that
came out of the University of
Chicago about control.
And what it really was, was this
reactive planning from
the early '90s, but elaborated
to the n-th degree, where we
just had tons of code for every
possible situation,
every frame, deciding
what should the
basketball player do next?
Well, is he doing this?
Hes' doing this.
We have hundreds of heuristics
that are all watching what--
should he pass, should
he not pass?
If I had the ball, would I have
a better shot than if I
passed it to Colt and
he had the ball?
If I pass the ball to Colt,
would it get intercepted?
All these things, and you're
calculating that every frame.
COLT MCANLIS: If you
hand me the ball, I
generally take the shot.
That's how it works.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, and
then, you know--
TODD KERPELMAN: Doesn't matter
where he is on the court.
WOLFF DOBSON: I mean, you
actually put in emotion things
like that, where it's like,
a guy like Kobe, he
holds onto the ball.
And it has some funny side
effects, which is if you have
one character who's really out
of balance, he'll never pass.
Because no matter what, he is
the best guy with the ball.
So yeah, I'm rarely a practicing
scientist now,
although I still review papers
for the AAAI Conference on
computer games.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
There's a whole lot about
you I did not know.
Are neural networks-- like
are those passe now?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, no.
People still do neural
networks.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Wasn't the cat
detector a neural network?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, neural
networks are still very
interesting.
There's lots of--
I mean, I had sort of good
old-fashioned AI kind of
stuff, where we are
doing symbolic
representations of things.
But there is also--
machine learning
is really big.
Machine learning in games is
very interesting because
machine learning is about
optimization.
A lot of times, it doesn't
actually sell very well when
you're doing it in a game.
So if you're playing a football
game and you're doing
machine learning on what kind
of plays the guy is doing or
something like that, it will
gradually start getting better
than you or being able to
predict every move you're
going to make.
And that's not actually
that much fun.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's not fun
to continually lose?
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, you--
COLT MCANLIS: Ask
the programmer.
It's super fun.
WOLFF DOBSON: You don't see
it, and you don't--
if you're doing this gradual
optimization process, you
don't have any place where you
can call attention to and say,
this is the moment in which
I learned something, and
therefore, I will
tell you this.
Which is why machine
learning--
so if you have a machine
learning thing, a neural
network that's driving your
car, you can't really tell
it's being driven by a neural
network unless you annotate it
with a whole bunch of stuff,
like, oh, he's missed the
curve, or something like this.
So machine learning is
really interesting.
It's really interesting
in games.
But again, it tends to show up
in quiet ways that you can't
quite see it.
You have showy stuff instead,
to like, look at this AI.
It's being so smart.
That tends to be more of
good old-fashioned AI.
COLT MCANLIS: What do you feel
about modern games today?
Do you think that too much of
the AI isn't really AI?
Because I know a lot of it is
pretty much just pre-canned.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, there's a
whole discussion of what--
every time something gets
popular, a lot of times, the
AI establishment says,
well, that was never
really AI all along.
That was an optimization
problem or
something like this.
For a long time, it was
believable agents.
You know, how could you make
sidekicks who were believable,
who seemed like they were
alive and things?
And then at some point, we
started making games then had
believable agents, dogs
that acted like
dogs, things like that.
There's interesting research--
No, but like CatZ, C-A-T-Z, the
little pet cats that you
could have from Broderbund.
I mean, those were moments,
like, believable agents.
Yeah, we can do that.
Eh, that's not really AI.
And it goes all the way back to
computer games learning, AI
learning how to play chess.
At some point, oh,
that's not chess.
That's just a search problem.
Or that's not AI,
that's search.
COLT MCANLIS: Well, that's
the goal, right?
I mean, chemistry is really
just physics,
which is really just--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
Well, what I would say about
games not really having real
AI, what I would actually say
about that is that you only
need to add as much AI to your
game to make it fun.
So there are situations like
if you play Yakuza or
something like that, the AI for
the guys getting out of
your way as you're running
through the crowd is sort of
silly looking.
They sort of stagger and they
pop to these weird animations,
and all this other stuff.
But you know what?
It's good enough.
I can get through the crowd.
They get of my way.
And so I think a lot of people,
especially when I was
in grad school, I would play
these games and think, oh my
gosh, if they just used our
awesome super-advanced
algorithms, it wouldn't
do this.
And then when you think about
it, it's like, it's not really
worth the money to get it
that beautiful or to
make it that seamless.
And if it isn't perfect and
seamless, you don't even
notice how good it is.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Not just
the money, but also the
computation, right?
Like, how much computational
effort is it worth--
TODD KERPELMAN: How much
can you spend towards--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, towards
crowd algorithms when you
don't really notice.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, exactly.
I mean, if it's happening--
or a classic example
of this is playing
first-person shooters.
If your sidekicks are not--
if you're playing a single
player game and your sidekicks
are not visible, they could
be doing anything.
And in fact, they usually are.
They're teleporting around.
They're doing crazy stuff.
Because it does not matter what
they're doing, because
you can't see them.
TODD KERPELMAN: I have noticed
occasionally if some follower--
I think this happens in Skyrim--
some follower isn't
able to path-find to where
I am, just keep going and
eventually they turn
the corner.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yep, and
they're right there.
And if you think about that,
it's good enough.
If you're involved in playing
your game, and the guy is
there at the right moment, you
don't really think about, did
he successfully path-plan his
way from point A to point B.
COLT MCANLIS: Now there's been
interesting cases of that.
Wasn't it Fable or Fable II?
One of the two had a mission you
could send your horse on
or something like you could move
a zone, and move another
zone, and then the horse would
still try to follow you
through these zones and in the
process would of course take
damage and gain experience
points along the way.
And there was this interesting
video on the net where someone
was like, OK, horse, stay.
And then he went like two zones
away, and he whistled
for his horse.
And the horse came back two
levels higher or something
like that, because it had killed
mice along the way, or
some weird stuff.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's beautiful,
and as an AI
developer, I think
that's so cool.
As somebody who would be
budgeting that game, I would
say to myself, why did we
spend all this money on
off-screen horses?
If we could get three more good
horses on screen, I would
totally skip the horse playing
the game by itself.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, we're
going to move along to
our next topic.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sorry
TODD KERPELMAN: No,
this is totally--
well, this great, right?
WOLFF DOBSON: Clearly, we
there's an AI episode.
TODD KERPELMAN: We could
an entire episode
just on game AI.
There's a lot more
to talk about.
But we're going to move into
our five-for-five section--
WOLFF DOBSON: Five for five.
TODD KERPELMAN: --where we--
yeah, we pick five topics that
we're going to talk about for
five minutes.
I actually have my stopwatch set
for 5 minutes, 30 seconds,
because I want us to have
a little extra time.
And we always go over anyway.
COLT MCANLIS: He's feeling
generous today.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes, I am.
So I'm going to start with a
comment that Colt had made
right before this episode, which
is basically declaring
that 3D was dead.
Why don't you back up this
claim, and then we'll all tell
you why you're wrong.
WOLFF DOBSON: Unlike our
completely uncontroversial
statements about game AI,
now we're going to say
whether 3D is dead.
COLT MCANLIS: So let
me preface this.
So I'm a graphics programmer,
traditionally.
Before I came to Google, I spent
time in the industry as
a system and graphics
programmer, like hardcore.
The question that I had today
was, where does 3D fit in our
modern gaming ecosystem?
We saw over the trend of a
couple console cycles that the
amount of cost to create these
movie production games
skyrocketed, mostly due to the
advances in 3D rendering.
But what we've seen now is that
the move to casual mobile
social doesn't require the
same sort of Hollywood
backdrop, right?
We've seen better experiences
coming out of 2D environments
and more creativity coming from
low-cost development.
In addition to that, with
the move to mobile--
your little stopwatch right
there-- we actually find that
these things aren't really
set up to do 3D well.
It burns through the battery.
It burns through the chips.
It takes a lot more away
from the user.
So the question is, besides the
console, is 3D really the
next step for tablet mobile?
Or is that really an ecosystem
that should be
dominated by 2D?
And the same thing for the
web, is there a spot
for 3D on the web?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So production
values for 3D content are
extremely high.
And mobile titles sell
for very little.
You can't really sustain a
multimillion dollar game
budget when you're selling
your unit for $0.99.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, unless
you're making Infinity Blade,
and selling it for however
much it is now.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: $9.99 or
something like that.
WOLFF DOBSON: It could be that
3D is the thing that persuades
people that this game is worth,
yeah, $4.99, instead of
$0.99, or instead
of free to play.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sure, yeah.
But I mean, I still think that
modern, really high-quality
AAA games sell for $70 a pop.
And they are in development for
four years and have huge
armies of programmers
and artists.
And even selling a game for $10,
it's hard to recoup those
costs, I think.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well,
but some of that--
some of that is tools.
If you have good tools, you
don't need that army of
programmers.
What you need is an
army of artists.
COLT MCANLIS: Unless
you're writing a
really good AI algorithm.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Then
it does it for you.
TODD KERPELMAN: How
much of this--
WOLFF DOBSON: Actually, in all
seriousness, I read a paper
about that a while ago where
they were actually generating
buildings complete-- filled
with everything down to
pencils on the desk from
basically AI algorithms.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's great if
you want to have kind of--
if you have a whole bunch of
geometry, like a city, that
can very easily be procedurally
generated.
We all kind of know what
a city looks like.
But gamers of 3D games and
gamers expect very cinematic
experiences, which is
essentially like you are
scripting a movie scene
that the player
gets to play through.
And in that case, it's difficult
to procedurally
generate that.
Because the helicopter has to
come in now and blow this city
block up at that moment.
TODD KERPELMAN: See, I don't
know all this has necessarily
anything to do with it being in
3D versus people just sort
of wanting big set piece
kinds of games.
I mean, there's obviously--
if you take something like--
why am I blanking on it--
Minecraft.
Obviously, a 3D game, obviously
a still simplistic
stylized art style, was done
fairly inexpensively.
It's not like there's anything
inherent in 3D that I think
sort of makes it more expensive,
so much as people
kind of want the big games.
They want the big experiences.
And if somehow 3D had never
been invented and we were
still doing 2D, we would be
complaining about the cost of
hiring all these animators
to hand draw all
these cells and how--
I think we'd be talking about
resolutions are getting
bigger, so sprites are getting
bigger, and my god, everyone
wants to customize everything,
and we
want 60 frames a second--
WOLFF DOBSON: I think there's an
alternate universe, like a
TV show, if 3D was
never invented.
TODD KERPELMAN: Those guys
would be saying, if only
things were in 3D then we
would have to span--
WOLFF DOBSON: If only
I had a Z buffer.
TODD KERPELMAN: --90 frames
drawing write this walk cycle.
COLT MCANLIS: Let's
do it this way.
Google fires you today.
You start a game company.
Is your game 3D or 2D?
Go.
WOLFF DOBSON: Depending
on how this show goes.
COLT MCANLIS: Is your
game 3D or 2D?
You start a game studio.
Google fires you.
Is your game 3D or 2D?
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh gosh, it
absolutely comes down to what
I'm building.
COLT MCANLIS: Well, no.
Right now, is it 3D or 2D?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: 2D.
Done.
TODD KERPELMAN: Eh,
2 and 1/2 D.
WOLFF DOBSON: I would probably
do 3D because it would be a
differentiating factor.
TODD KERPELMAN: Daniel Cook
had a really interesting
point, which was like, if
you're a small budget
developer, you can't compete on
massive art budgets, so you
go for the stylized stuff.
And when you kind of stop and
think about it, every indie
game, whether it's 3D or 2D,
something like Fez, is still
kind of done in sort of
a stylized art style.
So that you don't actually
care whether--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's funny
that you bring that up,
because this week, Mike Acton
just asked his Twitter
followers, like hey, do you
think that the push towards
realistic graphics is improving
or harming the
quality of games?
And the very nonscientific poll
came back saying people
don't like it as much.
They prefer the stylized
approach.
I would have to say I often like
games that are stylized.
I think one of the prettiest
games I've ever played was
Wind Waker.
That game is just beautiful, and
it looks nothing like real
life, but it looks like
an awesome cartoon.
WOLFF DOBSON: Going back a
little bit, about the tools, I
mean, this is--
like part of the reason why,
if I were starting my game
studio, I would think about 3D
because everybody can do 2D.
And if I have the special
skills, and find the right
people, and invest in the
pipeline at the beginning, I
mean this is what makes--
why 2D is cheap and
3D is expensive.
3D, you've got to set
up a pipeline.
You've got to get a rig,
animation, all this stuff.
And you have to figure out how
to get those into your game in
some sane way.
And there are tools like
Unity where they do
some of that for you.
But you still have to build
the pipeline from your
modelers to the motion models
and to the game finally.
And that's very expensive.
That's a big upfront cost.
With a 2D game, dude, I've just
got to get some sprites
up there, and that's
all I need.
But for every level I add onto
the 3D game, I have to do a
lot less work than for every
level I have to add on--
TODD KERPELMAN: That is true.
WOLFF DOBSON: Each new animation
costs exactly the
same for a 2D game, but each
new animation in my 3D game
costs almost nothing,
because I'm just
moving the rig around.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, well,
we're going to move on.
We're out of time Next topic,
Dart, Dart as a language.
Obviously--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it's pretty sweet.
TODD KERPELMAN: -we've been
chatting about it quite a bit
here at Google.
COLT MCANLIS: It's exciting.
It's a really cool language.
TODD KERPELMAN: I mean, how do
we think it's going to affect
the game industry?
How do you think
game developers
could make use of Dart?
WOLFF DOBSON: You know who
really knows about this is JJ.
TODD KERPELMAN: Shh, dude.
Don't say JJ's name aloud.
If you do, if you say it three
times, he appears.
WOLFF DOBSON: Who?
JJ?
TODD KERPELMAN: JJ.
COLT MCANLIS: Ahh!
JJ BURNS: Did somebody
say my name?
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh jeez!
COLT MCANLIS: How long have
you been down there?
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh my
god, he lives there.
JJ BURNS: You really
don't want to know.
TODD KERPELMAN: Dude, don't
look in that coffee can.
We're going to start.
TODD KERPELMAN: Hi, JJ.
JJ BURNS: Howdy.
TODD KERPELMAN: Hey buddy.
TODD KERPELMAN: How's
it going?
WOLFF DOBSON: Did
not expect that.
JJ BURNS: Nice to be here.
COLT MCANLIS: JJ, by the
way everyone, is--
introduce yourself
to the crowd.
JJ BURNS: I'm JJ Burns I'm a
developer advocate for Dart.
TODD KERPELMAN: Excellent.
So why don't you tell us why
should game developers care
about Dart?
What do they need to
know about Dart?
COLT MCANLIS: Does it increase
your cloaking ability,
apparently?
JJ BURNS: Well, the thing about
building web games these
days is that it's hard.
And the larger the game
is, the harder it is.
Because JavaScript wasn't
really built for
coding in the large.
When it first came out, web
apps didn't really exist.
And so Dart tries to retrofit
and fix a lot of those
problems with optional
static typing.
I like to say that it's kind of
a scalable language in that
it scales with the size
of your project.
If I wanted to build a game
with 100 developers and a
million lines of code, I'd want
to do it in Dart, not
JavaScript.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Absolutely.
TODD KERPELMAN: And so--
and I guess we sort of talked
about this before in previous
discussions, but Dart does
compile essentially into
JavaScript if you are on a
browser that does not support
native client.
JJ BURNS: That's right.
There's a VM that's been
integrated into a fork of
Chromium, and that's
called Dartium.
But since almost no one runs
Dartium, we have it compiling
down to JavaScript.
And one of the interesting
things about is the Dart to JS
compiler can actually
compile JavaScript--
TODD KERPELMAN: Hold on, Jimmy's
telling us something.
What's that?
Oh, you can pick it up, hey.
That's why we had this mic
sitting here this whole time.
In case some random person
living in our
studio popped up.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: In case somebody
has cut a hole in the
back of the studio and
crawled through.
COLT MCANLIS: What
is this thing?
Why is this over here?
Like I'm leaning away.
I thought it was a stage mic.
TODD KERPELMAN: Anyway,
let's--
JJ BURNS: The Dart to JS guys,
they're pretty amazing in that
they're not trying to do just
like straightforward
one-to-one translation between
Dart and JavaScript, but
rather, they're applying all
kinds of interesting
optimizations.
So a lot of times, the
JavaScript that they can
compile down to is actually
faster than the JavaScript
that you could write by hand.
Because they can do all
kinds of tricks like
in-lining and so forth.
And so you'll see this
once in a while.
If you end up looking at the
generated JavaScript, it's
like whoa, look at what they
did to me my code.
That's not what I wrote.
But it's kind of brilliant.
COLT MCANLIS: So for game
developers out there who don't
have exposure to Dart, but come
from the web, what are
the big three things
they should know?
If they're an action script
developer or a Flash
developer, what are the three
things they should know that
make Dart awesome?
JJ BURNS: Let me see.
I would think of it in terms
of the three types of
programmers.
So if you're an ActionScript 3
developer, I think that you're
going to find Dart
very familiar.
Because syntactically, it's
somewhere between
JavaScript and Java.
It's got the optional
static types things.
So I think that the ActionScript
3 developer will
find it very comfortable.
Now if you're a JavaScript
guy, you might be used to
tools not helping you out
enough, not catching errors
early enough, not being able
to refactor in ways, not
understanding your
code well enough.
And I think that the Dart editor
is going to really
surprise you in what
it can do.
Now, the third way, if you're
from like a C# Java
background, you're probably used
to really, really solid
development tools like Visual
Studio and IntelliJ.
And you might look at JavaScript
and say I just
can't do it.
I know that John said
this before that--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There are
no rules in JavaScript.
There's no rules.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's what
I love about JavaScript.
There are no rules.
JJ BURNS: If you can think like
a Lisp guy, or Python,
Perl, Ruby hacker, then
JavaScript makes a lot of
sense, but if you're coming from
a C# Java background, it
might be a little bit
frustrating, and I think that
Dart alleviates a lot
of that frustration.
WOLFF DOBSON: Speaking as
somebody who has a PhD in AI,
I frickin' love Lisp.
Sorry, I'm distracting
from you.
COLT MCANLIS: Quick
question here.
So game development is
all the performance.
JJ BURNS: Yes.
COLT MCANLIS: And When it comes
down to the metal, we
care about how you can iterate
over the arrays, how we can
optimize for that.
So what does Dart bring to the
table for games that care
about performance?
JJ BURNS: So actually, I think
John could talk about this a
little bit.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Absolutely.
I've been working with the
Dart VM team to make this
fast, to make things like vector
math faster under the
Dart VM than is currently
possible
in any other language.
So by extending access to
floating point arrays so that
you could do things like convert
a four-by-four matrix
that's stored inside an array
using the SIMD extensions that
your CPU has, these sorts of
algorithms can be greatly
accelerated.
COLT MCANLIS: Fantastic.
So we can do fast
linear algebra.
We can do transforms.
We can do processing.
WOLFF DOBSON: Tell me about
debugging tools, like when I'm
trying to live debug Dart.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: This is
an awesome thing.
Dart has an IDEA.
It has tools.
It has a type system.
And you set breakpoints
in your editor.
It's all the way there.
That's awesome.
You set breakpoints
in the editor.
You launch your application.
It's running in Dartium.
The breakpoint hits.
It goes back to the editor.
There you go.
You can fan out your
variables, look
at your call stack.
JJ BURNS: Look at your
stack, yeah.
Look at your variables, mouse
over a variable in the source
code, and it will show
you the value.
COLT MCANLIS: And is the plan
to migrate that from Dartium
to Chromium?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think that
in the future that's a
possibility.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I'll end
with one final question.
So obviously, in JavaScript
right now, there's a lot of
libraries, Box2D for physics,
stuff to kind of help manage
graphics, all of that.
Like Dart, my impression
is it's just
starting as a language.
Are those libraries available,
and can I use them just as
JavaScript?
How does that work?
JJ BURNS: I would break the
libraries into two categories.
There's things like jQuery.
And I always like to say that
Dart is its own jQuery,
because Dart provides a
nicer API for the DOM.
As far as the Box2D,
there's a port of--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, actually
there's a port being developed
by Dominic Hamon, who
works at Google.
And I've actually been working
with him on optimizing my
vector math library for
the Box2D port.
TODD KERPELMAN: What
about graphics?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I have a
graphics engine, which
presents something closer to
console graphics APIs and
DirectX 11 graphics APIs,
rather than WebGL.
Then a demo, like higher-level
library that sits on top of
that allows you to have a
dynamically hot reloadable
scene graph and all kinds
of animations
and things like that.
COLT MCANLIS: And this
is the public, right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, it's
all on my GitHub.
JJ BURNS: Yeah that's the really
nice thing about Dart
is that it is fully
open source and
developed in the open.
And so you could look at John
and I yelling at each other
over code reviews
and so forth.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Over breakfast
every day.
WOLFF DOBSON: I actually can
frequently hear that.
JJ BURNS: Yeah, well,
you know.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All
the way from 19--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
I'm just sitting in 1900, and
I can hear you guys shouting
at each other.
JJ BURNS: It's true.
TODD KERPELMAN: So thank you
very much for dropping--
what you going to do now?
Are you just going
to hang out?
JJ BURNS: I've got to go
back to work, man.
I can't pop up during
every GDL, man.
I've got work to do.
TODD KERPELMAN: We've got
to remember not to
say his name again.
And he's out.
Sh!
Careful.
Don't say his name
three times.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, he'll
have to come back.
I'm going to let you finish
about your Dart talk, but that
VM was the best.
That--
I did not know he
was back there.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm
frightened now.
What's the next subject?
Do we have more people
back there?
COLT MCANLIS: Next time, we need
to get Sergey back there.
Have him pop up with
some Google Glass.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
would be fantastic.
I'll talk to him about that.
COLT MCANLIS: Jimmy, can you
send an email on that?
JIMMY: Saying his name
three times does
not make him appear.
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, next topic.
We didn't really talk--
we sort of
missed this last time--
Valve.
Big picture mode on scene.
WOLFF DOBSON: The big picture.
And presumably at some point,
some type of Valve-specific
hardware coming out.
What do we think
about all this?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think
it's pretty exciting.
Valve has been investing heavily
in OpenGL and, in
particular, Linux performance.
So if I were to take a guess,
I would say that whatever
Valve is producing is going to
be running Linux because of
how much they've been publicly
putting into R&D on the Linux
OpenGL stack.
It's really exciting.
I, at some point in time, kind
of stopped gaming on my PC
because I like the idea of
sitting around on the couch.
I missed that experience of
hanging out with friends in
the living room, playing the
games, and that seems to be
what the Steam Box Big Picture
mode is all about.
WOLFF DOBSON: One of
the reasons why--
I mean, I'm a huge Steam fan,
and one of the things that's
great about it is
it just works.
Like when you download a game
and you play it, it just works
as opposed to--
COLT MCANLIS: Have you tried
the Big Picture mode?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, I haven't
tried Big Picture mode.
But I'm saying just in general,
they have this
experience that to me, as a
console developer, it felt
like console games.
You just go, you click on the
game you want to play, you hit
play, and you're playing
the game, often.
But when you're installing the
game off disks, I remember
there was this point where
I-- it took me--
I think I started Doom 3 seven
times, trying to get it-- like
the settings in some sane way
in which people's faces
weren't peeling off.
Just like I'm never--
TODD KERPELMAN: That might have
been part of the game.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That
was intended.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, but it was
during the opening cut scenes,
which they were clearly not.
You were always seeing the back
of people and the back of
people's faces and stuff.
And I was like, I'm never--
was it that?
Oh no, sorry, it just getting-
incredibly tarry, and I was
like, OK, I'm never playing
on a PC again.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I would love to
have all of the games that
are on Steam in my living room
on my TV, holding some
kind of game pad.
I would jump at that.
WOLFF DOBSON: If they can agree
on the game pad layout,
then it's a wonderful thing,
because you can then code to
that, and it's a--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And you actually
get to target PC
games and this new
meta console.
COLT MCANLIS: Is that sort
of like-- so you
mentioned that, right?
If everyone can agree on a
controller layout, is that the
logical flow?
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, well, that's
pretty important.
We have all agreed that
there's a keyboard
and there's a mouse.
And that the keys are in this
order unless you're like a
Dvorak person.
Even those people when
they're sitting down
to play Team Fortress--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: With
Dvorak for WASC.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
It's like--
TODD KERPELMAN: You've got
to play like this.
COLT MCANLIS: No, it's Dvorak.
Just type Dvorak.
Every game, you just type Dvorak
over and over and over.
WOLFF DOBSON: But in all
seriousness, like controls are
what makes games.
And you need to make sure
that the thing you're
touching is the same.
So if one guy is sitting there
like, yeah, I just press this
button, and it puts on the
handbrake, and I can spin
around turns.
The other guy's like, I have to
the left trigger and press
the left joystick at the same
time, and I can't--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Actually,
that's a great point.
I mean, if they were to present
some kind of like
Steam Box home console,
the quality of
the game pad is key.
I mean, if it's just take any
game pad off of the Best Buy
shelves, I don't think it'll be
that good of an experience.
But if there is a, this is the
Steam Box game pad that--
COLT MCANLIS: We need to
go back to power glove.
Make it happen, Nintendo.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Bring it back.
WOLFF DOBSON: We gave
you the Wii.
What do you want?
COLT MCANLIS: It's not
in glove form.
So here's my question
for everybody.
What's driving this?
In reality, I think we all
agree that Steam is a
fantastic product.
It's been probably, in my
personal opinion, keeping
gaming on desktops alive.
TODD KERPELMAN: I think they've
done a huge service to
the PC gaming industry.
COLT MCANLIS: Absolutely.
When we saw consoles
taking over, we
saw a big trend there.
Even the switch to mobile and
web now, I think it's safe to
say that Steam is still
standing alone.
Why the move to console?
What's driving that?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Gabe has come
out and said that he's very
unhappy with Windows 8.
He doesn't think that's going
to deliver as good of
experience for gamers.
TODD KERPELMAN: I think he used
the word "catastrophe."
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it was very strong.
TODD KERPELMAN: It was
very strongly worded.
I mean, clearly some
of this is from--
it appears as though Microsoft
is going to put its own
version of Steam into the
operating system.
I think it's going
to make it--
well, I don't exactly know
what they're doing, but I
think they want to make their
own app store that is probably
going to be a lot more visible
than whatever you would have
to do to get to Steam.
I haven't used Windows 8.
I don't know.
This is all just speculation.
COLT MCANLIS: Also, there's
kittens everywhere.
TODD KERPELMAN: But
clearly, they're
saying, gee, we're awfully--
WOLFF DOBSON: That's YouTube.
TODD KERPELMAN: --we're
awfully tied to--
they are kind of at the mercy of
one, possibly two companies
that are not them, running
these platforms.
WOLFF DOBSON: I just think the
other thing is that it's the
continuous upgrade.
I find this with car
electronics.
My wife has a car that's got
a built-in Maps thing, or a
built in GPS in the
radio or whatever.
And my incredibly old car, I
have an aftermarket thing that
I just put my Android
phone in.
And every time I buy
a better Android
phone, my car gets better.
I think the same thing goes with
the Steam Box experience
or this Big Picture experience,
which is it's been
how long since the Xbox
360 came out?
Waiting for these hardware
cycles for the console
industry, especially where we're
at this point where 3D
games with 3,000 polygons per
character look about the same
as games with 7,000 polygons
per character.
At that point, eh, what's
the hurry to upgrade?
But if you're a hardcore gamer,
and I think Steam
definitely leans into that
hardcore market, you're going
to keep upgrading your PC as you
go along, which means your
console going to get-- your
console, your Big Picture, is
going to better and better
as you go along.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, that kind
of goes against the whole
dedicated Steam Box idea.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
I would really--
WOLFF DOBSON: But the trick
with that is that they can
keep releasing Steam Box 2,
Steam Box 3, Steam Box 4, and
since they're all PC games at
their heart, they're just
going to keep getting better.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sure, but I
mean I think one of the
biggest reasons why I moved
away from PC gaming was
because of that upgrade
treadmill, which was every
year a new game came that
required a new GPU and a new
faster CPU.
TODD KERPELMAN: It made you
feel awesome when you went
down to the store and you're
like, put down your $600.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It was lot of
fun, but console games also
continue to look better and get
better as the life cycle
goes on because they figure
out a way to extract more
performance out of--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TODD KERPELMAN: It is nice
knowing that a console game is
coming out and I just know
it will work on my Xbox.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TODD KERPELMAN: I have
to look at the specs.
COLT MCANLIS: We've got to--
TODD KERPELMAN: We've
got to move on.
We've got to move on to--
this is a question
from Dr. Dobson.
Who's your favorite sidekick
in a game?
WOLFF DOBSON: That's
a real scientific
question right there.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, it's
a good one because we've
talking about AI.
We talked about the
Fable horse.
WOLFF DOBSON: I will give you
two favorite sidekicks.
The first one is Alex from
Half-Life, Episode 2.
Because there, they really spent
the time lingering on
her emotional state as part of
yours, like how she feels
about this world.
I went through and played the
beginning of it again just the
other day, and I was like,
wow, this is really neat.
I know what she's feeling
because I'm looking at her
face and sort of seeing
what's going on.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And Freeman
is blank, right?
WOLFF DOBSON: He's you.
He's everyman.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So she's
reflecting emotions that you
should probably be feeling
back onto you.
WOLFF DOBSON: I wanted
to go on an
adventure with her forever.
I felt the same--
it was just like,
this is great.
I mean, except that world is
sort of a horrible one to live
in, but that's a different
problem.
COLT MCANLIS: Besides all
the death and the
robots and the aliens.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: But hey,
at least she's here.
WOLFF DOBSON: Exactly.
But at least I have somebody--
COLT MCANLIS: For some reason,
that tells me that should be a
Hallmark card.
Besides the aliens and the
robots, thanks for being here.
WOLFF DOBSON: You are
the girl for me.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Fascist
government system.
WOLFF DOBSON: I also think that
the fact that she doesn't
go and get herself killed all
the time is super important.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
You don't get frustrated
with her.
WOLFF DOBSON: She takes
logical cover.
She falls back which
she's supposed to.
And she isn't clearly
invincible, but in practice,
it turns out she is.
The other thing--
the other companion is the D
that you get in NetHack that
follows you around at the
beginning, who, if you play
like I do, when you finally run
out of food on level four,
you kill him and eat him.
He's like, not only a best
friend, but also a meal.
And I just want to tell
you all that--
COLT MCANLIS: Why do I think
that Wolff is going to quit
Google one day and make a
Half-Life 2 meets NetHack
clone, where in level four,
he's really conflicted.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
COLT MCANLIS: For like a week,
he's just like, what did I do?
WOLFF DOBSON: It's alive.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's The
Road, in game form.
Wow, I'm really running
out of food here.
Wow, that is like a
whole different
version of Oregon Trail.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Well,
one of us made it.
COLT MCANLIS: And we all sort
of made it, because you're a
part of me now.
TODD KERPELMAN: The Donner Party
edition of Oregon Trail.
All right.
John?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Go to Colt.
I've got to think about this.
TODD KERPELMAN: Colt?
COLT MCANLIS: So I'm going to
go back to a Valve favorite
and actually say GLaDOS.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, I thought you
were going to go with the
companion cube.
COLT MCANLIS: I was not going to
go with the companion cube.
I think that's a little
overdone.
A lot of people underestimate
the drive that GLaDOS brings
to the table.
She motivates you.
TODD KERPELMAN: Are you talking
about number one or
two, when she's in the potato?
WOLFF DOBSON: Spoiler.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
I'm sorry.
COLT MCANLIS: What's
up with that?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You
haven't played a
two-year old game yet.
No, in Portal 1.
I think what they
did to bring--
WOLFF DOBSON: She is a wonderful
companion there.
COLT MCANLIS: She
was an amazing
companion and sidekick.
She got you where you
needed to go.
She motivated you even if it
meant giving you the pointy
end of the stick.
Even though she tried to kill
you, which I think that all
good sidekicks should
try to kill their--
WOLFF DOBSON: If you make the
dog mad in NetHack, he will
come after you.
COLT MCANLIS: Well, that's
because he saw what you did to
the D.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Kind of aloe the
same lines as Alex, I've
really enjoyed the sidekicks
that you get
in Uncharted games.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes!
Oh, Elena is another
example of a--
there was a wonderful moment
in Uncharted 3 where--
or 2, I guess it is, where
you're walking through Nepal
and your two ex-girlfriends
are fighting with--
are arguing and talking about
you, and you're just--
the character is doing--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It
feels so natural.
COLT MCANLIS: When I'm walking
through the streets of Nepal,
it brings back so
many memories.
WOLFF DOBSON: But in all
seriousness, the fact that
they were having this wonderful
conversation that
was completely grounded in the
story that you're having, and
it was bringing their
characters
forward, it was amazing.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm
going to go with--
I've got two picks.
One would probably be the dog
or cat in Torchlight.
Because they're useful.
WOLFF DOBSON: You know that
dog is getting like
a 50% cut of every--
TODD KERPELMAN: I don't care.
He's going back to town for me,
doing all the work that I
don't want to do.
WOLFF DOBSON: This is what
younger siblings were for when
you were growing up.
COLT MCANLIS: Back
on the farm.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm sure he's
embezzling money from me, but
I don't care.
And number two--
WOLFF DOBSON: You have
to audit the dog.
It's a really boring
video game.
COLT MCANLIS: He's got
a great lawyer.
Weird thing.
Number two, I'll go with--
what is it, HK-47?
WOLFF DOBSON: Ah, kill
all the meatbags.
Ah, I love that.
This was the best robot ever.
He was the anti C-3PO.
For those of you who haven't
played the game, in Knights of
the Old Republic, you got
a Droid sidekick.
And his thesis was kill
all the meatbags.
He barely tolerated you, and any
human, he was just like--
he was the polar opposite of
every robot that had ever been
in Star Wars.
It was wonderful.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yep.
An assassin robot, and
he was hilarious.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I like that
term "meatbag." I've never
really thought of us
as bags of meat.
TODD KERPELMAN: You have this
whole conversation with him
about why do you call
me meatbag?
And he's like, well, it's
kind of what you are.
You're bags, and you're
full of meat.
COLT MCANLIS: It's sort of Fifth
Element style, like, are
you humanoid?
Identify yourself.
Negative, I'm a meat popsicle.
TODD KERPELMAN: So let's
move on to--
we've got time.
We're kind of running low.
Maybe we just go into
what we're playing--
WOLFF DOBSON: I think we should
do what we're playing.
TODD KERPELMAN: --and save the
fifth topic for next time.
So all right, we'll go--
we'll start with Colt.
COLT MCANLIS: No, he
deferred last time.
TODD KERPELMAN: We'll
start with John.
You're right John, what
are you playing?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right,
so I am playing--
WOLFF DOBSON: We've heard your
trials with 100 Floors.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, I've
been playing 100
Floors a lot lately.
TODD KERPELMAN: Ha, ha!
Got ya!
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It is a
frustrating experience, but it
just keeps pulling me back.
I keep going on my phone.
I'm like all right, I'm going to
make it through this floor.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's such a slot
machine of I got it, I got it!
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Some of
the stages, I just--
as soon as I see the layout of
the stage, I'm like, oh, doo,
doo, doo, and I'm onto
the next floor.
And other ones, I'm
stuck for a day.
And actually, in the end when
I succeed, it makes sense.
I'm kind of like, yeah,
I see that.
And there's just something
about--
the game has these rough edges
that drives you away from the
obvious answer, but the answer
is always obvious.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's like
a programmer question.
Like what are you
not assuming?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, Colt.
What are you playing?
COLT MCANLIS: I'm actually
playing a handful of games
that are uninteresting.
I'm actually-- if you've been
following my Twitter feed or
my G+ feed, then you're probably
aware that I'm
working on trying to analyze
streaming algorithms and how
to get large game worlds
streamed off of disk and
through the internet
and whatnot.
And so I'm actually going
back to the table.
I'm actually trying to play a
lot of different games that
have done streaming very well
and very bad and sort of take
a technical look at them.
So I've been looking at
the elevator scenes
in Mass Effect 2.
Effect I've been taking a look
at the streaming system inside
of the source engine
for Valve.
I think they do a great
job of it there.
A lot of open world engines with
low load times, like GTA
and Jak and Daxter, and
those sorts of games.
WOLFF DOBSON: Run backwards
in Jak and Daxter.
Daxter.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah,
exactly, right?
And so just taking a look at a
handful of these things and
see how people are solving
the problem, where is the
technical hurdles?
How did they solve them?
See if I can't grok any
information out of it.
And if you're watching the show
and you've got a good
experience with streaming large
worlds, please send me
an email, send me a Tweet.
I'd love to talk with
you more about it.
TODD KERPELMAN: As for
me, let's see,
I've got three games.
On I'm still playing Skyrim,
and that will probably be a
standard answer for
quite a while now.
COLT MCANLIS: Took an
arrow to the knee.
TODD KERPELMAN: I am playing
The Walking Dead.
WOLFF DOBSON: Really?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Is it
working for you?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
Are you saying you had
technical problems?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, no, working
for you like I wasn't sure how
that would translate into a
point-and-click adventure.
TODD KERPELMAN: So it works
really well as sort of a piece
of storytelling.
The mood is really good.
The setting is really good.
The characters are
interesting.
The dialogue is well written.
You sort of play it, and it
really kind of gets you into
the feeling of like, I
am in a world where
zombies have taken over.
Sometimes I'll finish playing,
I'm ready to go to bed, and
I'm like, I'm going to lock the
door because I don't want
the zombie to come in.
And then I realize, no wait,
that was just the game.
The actual game play itself is
not particularly interesting.
It's a fair number of
conversation trees that I've
realized now, looking at a
couple of game FAQs, often
don't seem to have an effect.
WOLFF DOBSON: No.
You're entertaining yourself by
answering these questions.
TODD KERPELMAN: And then the
standard adventure game puzzle
type of things that--
WOLFF DOBSON: Use skunk
with white paint.
Use white paint on fence.
Use fence to get splinter.
TODD KERPELMAN: But
it is slight--
I will say their puzzles are
more logical than your typical
adventure games.
COLT MCANLIS: Better puzzles
than 100 Floors or worse?
TODD KERPELMAN: Different.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: 100
Floors is very--
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
like hey, we're--
that's like Myst.
And this is like Monkey
Island style.
Yeah, but anyway, I would say
just as an interesting piece
of storytelling, it's
totally worth it.
So, check it out
if you haven't.
And then on mobile,
I am playing--
I picked this up in the
$0.25 sale yesterday--
Let's Create Pottery, which is
a sort of pottery-making game
that after playing it, I'm
like, this is so obvious.
Why didn't anyone put a pottery
wheel on a mobile
touch device before?
You're just like, I'm going to
push it in here and pull it
out here, and you
get this vase.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There's
actually a really
awesome tech demo for--
that comes with Move
controllers for the
PlayStation 3 SDK where
it's essentially that.
You hold one Move controller and
you use the trigger and it
spins this long tube
of something.
And then you use the other
one, and you kind
of lathe in, like--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
COLT MCANLIS: --for the Move
controller which required to
like, dance around the base and
sculpt it with your hips.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Some of the
tech demos available to
developers with the Move
controller are the most
amazing usages of one-to-one
motion tracking
that you've ever seen.
Being able to spin this thing
and pull and have it come out
to and make all these weird
swords and clubs and things
like that, it's so
creative and fun.
WOLFF DOBSON: So for my--
I'm also playing a zombie game,
but I'm playing Lone
Survivor, which is a 2D game
that was clearly--
it's very pixely, and you
shouldn't be frightened of it,
and I can only play it for about
half hour at a time.
And then I'm like, I don't want
to go down that hallway.
I think I'm going to go work
on something else.
So yeah, I've been playing
like 31 minutes
a day of this game.
COLT MCANLIS: What platform
is that on?
WOLFF DOBSON: It's on Steam.
I'm playing on a Mac, but
it's on PC as well.
It's tight.
The sound design
is really good.
You hear the zombies far away.
And you're like, oh god,
zombies are coming.
And they don't groan.
They make this weird
staticky noise.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's more
Silent Hill, and it's--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, I guess
it is more Silent Hill.
I was getting kind of a Resident
Evil vibe off it,
because they give you the gun,
and it's totally ineffective.
COLT MCANLIS: It's been too long
since we've had a good
suspense style game.
The first Bioshock was the last
really good one that I
think came out.
We've been missing that
for a couple years.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, it's good.
I'm like I said, I haven't
gotten all the way through it
because it's too scary.
And on mobile, I'm playing
SteamBirds, which just--
I've been playing in my Nexus 7,
and it's exactly the right
size for a Nexus 7.
And it's got this beautiful
touch interface.
And it's just--
I'm sitting there, I'm at Go at
our cafe, with my sandwich
in one hand and playing
SteamBirds in the other.
It's totally fun.
This is what touch
gaming is about.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right, I
think we are out of time.
We've got no one else
behind there.
WOLFF DOBSON: No,
thank goodness.
TODD KERPELMAN: So remember,
don't say
JJ's name three times.
WOLFF DOBSON: Who, JJ?
TODD KERPELMAN: Shh.
No one.
And we'd like to thank you
for joining us for
Google Games Chat.
We will see you in two weeks.
I'd like to thank
my panelists--
COLT MCANLIS: Posse.
TODD KERPELMAN: --posse
for joining us.
COLT MCANLIS: Entourage.
TODD KERPELMAN: And we
will talk to you--
WOLFF DOBSON: I walk around in
front of Todd opening doors.
It's pretty much how we roll.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm the
good-looking one in the entourage.
TODD KERPELMAN: Uh-huh.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I don't
watch the show, so--
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm probably
E. I'm the shortest.
Anyway, we'll talk we'll
talk to you guys later.
Billy, you can fade us out.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Jimmy.
TODD KERPELMAN: Jimmy, sorry.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[MUSIC PLAYING]